mishap hissing is bumper-to-bumper here
we got Robert and Julie from Culver City
Oh lexan we were trying to rip they both
look very short could be the camera
showed he want a thug boy who showed he
found a whoa look at the titty committee
meeting up right on Julie's chest saying
they're having a little afternoon
convention right there where she is this
side of business meaning she showed up
with him tits out this is from this past
New Year's when he proposed that night
and she was ready with them pants
looking like a little a little Jersey
Shore mermaid Oh bro she looks like I'm
dizzy from them tits bro it's like a
blur made dude I can't even get a good
look at him again I can't see him I'm
seeing funny do you know what's so funny
I haven't even looked at him you know
but they look like a good young couple
looks like maybe they're about to get a
house together something how old are
they don't know they are but they're
seeing you at the Mirage in Vegas in
August oh they want you to be their
wedding officiant oh they're looking to
get divorced oh wow so they're actually
looking to get Oh a wedding officiant
what do I do
nothing usually give this order not it's
not that gathers hands there with the so
know you can item you can basically
whatever you want Oh y'all nighttime
dude I'm not doing all night though I'm
not doing all night man I'm not doing a
threesome no no you're not doing
anything like that I'm staying in my
room you might be a cook you know I'm
saying no I'm not doing anything like
that you're an idiot dude it's not my
thing it's his y'all want his girls tits
for the past 30 minutes he hasn't
mentioned that you mentioned it no you
brought it up does it say anybody a
lovely mermaid only thing we know about
him is Julie is worried that her
old-school Italian father will not like
this outfit she ain't lying well big
catch a swift palm to the face dressing
like that out the house I've had some
rare uh pescado and uh this is
definitely some she's dressed like a
real mahi-mahi right here if you look at
her you know it's like a nice little
tortellini something no that's not a
fish you delinquent yeah but they're
Italian brah
okay I'll barely meet you halfway on
this one thanks bro
no but you seem like a nice guy Brendan
and this guy seems like a good guy yeah
he seems cool though it'll work out
I think it'll work out look at him man
they they seem like they love each other
they're both looking in the same
direction and smiling short well I don't
know if they're short you know I can
tell you and I'll tell you they're how
do you know well I can just tell how do
you know how people are hmm she has big
heels on they just look shorter I don't
think so look at that plant
do you see that and that is a big plant
d what do you think short she looks they
look I don't yeah they look like about
five seven or that's I say five six five
seven they could still grow man you guys
have no hope nothing you have some
little meatballs running around right
now
no I'm I had some little euros yeah
that's what I like them beef gyoza I was
boy yeah you hit that rigatoni out the
Mirage dude I put one of those in the
corner of my mouth like a damn dip and
shoot hoops there's beef gyoza was you
ever had them I have it [ __ ] let's go
on man but good luck and look so if the
weddings the same weekend I'm there I'll
be inefficient but I'm sure I got to do
the show yeah you know if I could run
over there and efficient you know for a
little you could do it after yeah be a
lifeguard or something at the pool if
they want to do a swim after yeah you
jump in and save them no I'm not gonna
save men they got each other they
there's gonna save each other gonna do
something bro no lazy about if you're
gonna do it go full-bore yeah you're
right that's dress up bro yeah I'll do
something put a tuxedo on well tell them
thank you for the invite and uh
we'll send him um we'll send him a
wedding gift how about that it's at
least we can do some in one of our new
mergers yeah
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]